all right well is there any like marie
condo essence in your gardening do you
is there any of that involved yes i read
this incredible book i don't know you
would probably love it called braiding
sweetgrass
um by robin wall kimmerer and it was
about
an honorable harvest with your plants so
you're always thanking them and we have
a beautiful lemon tree and i use lemons
all the time and i would just go and
pick them and not even think about it
yeah but there's this whole process of
like asking the tree permission kind of
like when you're holding in the marie
condo thing when you're holding it
uh something and wondering if it sparks
joy and if it doesn't you say thank you
so much
and you pass it off but you always say
thank you so i would just grab lemons as
many as i wanted
and now i ask this sounds so frou-frou
but like you're like a moaning i am
owning it
um i i've been doing that voice a lot i
think that's my quarantine yeah i know
this is
impressive a little bit of rage yeah 20
20 range
yeah but i asked the lemon tree for
permission to take a lemon
and she says you do hear an answer
sometimes i think it might be
no and then i ask again and then i hear
you until you get your yes and i
and i give something back so it you can
either do like tobacco leaves or tea
or water you give something back to the
tree when you what do you mean so you
just lay it down like
like i'll sprinkle she recommends
sprinkling like fresh something that's
from the earth so like tobacco leaves or
water or like a a bartering system with
a battering system with mother i like
saying thank you because
we have not treated her great and we
have not but i'm going to be real with
you about my lemon tree
let's talk about it um my lemon tree
i don't ever have to ask okay beth
because there are literally 275
on the ground right now my lemon tree
like this house i got
it's i've never seen anything like it on
planet earth are you going to cook
something with them like a lot like
lemon bars
how many lemon things can you make i
know no it's it's
insane but but speaking of desserts
though your husband had a birthday not
too long ago right
well how did you celebrate i had a
pandemic birthday it was kind of sad
yeah it's just a pandemic birthday okay
yeah i tried to make it really special
i mean he he just rescued a horse oh so
what's the name and what
rosie oh okay so
he he rescued her um and so we started
the morning by i made him a blueberry
crumble which is the only thing i know
how to bake
wow uh yes sounds delicious and then we
went to the barn to see our
rescue horses that's awesome and had a
great day and then um
just i love that you live in l.a and
just said and then we went to the barn
yeah it's my happy place it's the only
place between my house that i've been
you know during quarantine because it's
outside and you know six feet apart and
12 yeah equine therapy too like being
around horses
in nature all that everything yeah
you're doing all the right things
checking all those boxes
yep um so do you also go all out like at
the holidays are you excited because
this is a new house
i'm excited to decorate my new house for
christmas
first of all kelly's album christmas
album is on vinyl oh my gosh
i love it so much i'm not gonna this
sounds so weird and i'm just gonna say
it's my favorite album i've ever made
it's i love christmas music you're me
too and my husband will not let me
listen till after thanksgiving
but this year i'm going to be listening
to christmas music as soon as i want
yes uh i love christmas i love
everything about it
i'm not very good at decker are you good
at it oh my god i love
well here's the thing i haven't been
able to decorate for the last
few years and we've had um actually my
husband's mother is
great at it like she does such a
beautiful job we've been working
but now that my house is like smaller
and a little more like i can do this
like i'm totally doing the christmas
feel i'm doing all of it
[Music]